Freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
ganz besonderen Video denn ich bin hier
heute nicht alleine sondern ich habe
einen alten Bekannten heute zu Gast den
lieben Karsten mein lieber schön dass du
hier bist du warst in einer der früheren
persönlicher kochfolgen zu Gast und die
Leute haben Dich nicht vergessen weil
als ich vor kurzem meine eigene
pastamarke angekündigt habe haben alle
geschrieben das muss Carsten testen das
muss der Restaurantkritiker testen und
das ist im Prinzip das was wir heute
Vorhaben was sind deine Gedanken wenn du
das hörst weil ja also ich ich finde es
ein heftiger Test weil das ist so dein
Baby da ganz viel ganz viel Herz BL drin
und wenn ich jetzt irgendwas kritisches
sage drehst wahrscheinlich den Hals nein
nein nein nein nein ich möchte wirklich
hundertprozentige Ehrlichkeit heute das
ist die Prämisse weil ich bin absolut
überzeugt vom Produkt ich liebe auch
gute Pasta also mein meiner Familie
gibt's zweifachen italienischen
Anschluss also bei uns wird Pasta auch
sehr hoch gehalten ich finde es ist so
das sou food par excellence pa macht
glücklich es gab letztens sogar
Untersuchung die bewiesen hat dass Pasta
glücklich macht also es wissenschaftlich
bewiesen und ich finde wenn einem eine
Sache so am Herzen liegt dann ist es
wichtig dass sie richtig gut ist das
Schwierige ist es gibt wenig Zutaten die
man eigentlich braucht für Soße und
Pasta und die müssen aber gut sein sonst
bricht das ganze Gericht auseinander das
ist genau das was wir herausgefunden wir
können ja noch mal gemeinsam reingucken
was uns hier erwartet natürlich die
Pasta poesia Box war super flott
ausverkauft deshalb noch mal vielen
vielen vielen Dank an dieser Stelle wir
arbeiten schon mit Hochdruck an den
nächsten Boxen aber du kannst ja mal
auspacken und gucken was Du hier so
siehst erstmal das pestogene Wese mag
die Farbe optisch sieht das schon mal
sieht das schon mal nach einem geilen
grün aus weiter geht's Ragu Bolognese
ich hätte jetzt gedacht dass das total
aber ist weiß also gut ist d D es auch
ein bisschen größere Fleischstücke gibt
das hat man manchmal bei einigen dieser
dieser fertig Dinger dass es alles so
durchgehächselt ist und dann schmeckst
du überhaupt nichts mehr von Fleisch es
muss ein paar größere Stücke drin geben
okay es klingt als wä irgendwie nicht
irgendwie so ein trickzutat drin mit der
man irgendwas pinnt sondern als wären es
die klassischen Zutaten und nicht noch
irgendwas oben drauf mit
e733 X sondern ist nur drin was
reingehört und ganz wichtig falls Leute
sagen ihr habt ja schon mal zusammeng
gedreht der Carsten so das ist sein Job
zu kritisieren und er macht das für für
Zeitung und auch schon in in anderer
Mission deshalb was von Carsten heute
gesagt wird wird ehrlich sein es wird
mir vielleicht weh tun vielleicht werde
ich mich freuen lohnt sich auf jeden
Fall dran zu bleiben um es
herauszufinden wir wollen ja auch Kritik
also wenn du uns jetzt sagst das muss
mehr nach Trüffel schmecken das soll
mehr dies das soll mehr das dann Trüffel
ist ein super Hees Thema weil ich hasse
so Trüffelöl das ist so für mich total
die absolute küchenpest wir hab nur nur
natürlichen Trüffel wenn ich im
Restaurant bin ich denke warum gibt i
noch Trüffelöl dran das gibt immer so
ein unangenehmen überintensiven falschen
Geschmack okay und blödes Produkt und da
da bin ich direkt raus deswegen erste
Blick hier ist Trüffelöl drin weil dann
hätt es mir eigentlich kaum servieren
müssen es ist nicht drin das ist
beruhigend ich merke ich merke auf jeden
Fall schon das ist spannend mit dir weil
du hast einen ganz anderen Blick auf die
Dinge aber wir müssen nichts verstecken
gut finde ich dass die Eier aus
Freilandhaltung sind das ist eine Sache
auf die ich bei ganz vielen Produkten
achte was anderes will ich eigentlich
gar nicht essen ich merke wirklich der
Carsten ich weiß schon warum ihr euch
das gewünscht hat weil der der Carsten
der guckt auf mit agus Augen auf alles
riech ruhig mal dran ja der Basilikum
Duft ist super stark und super frisch
auch und super clean also da liegt nicht
irgendwas muffiges drüber was man
manchmal hat auch im Nachgeschmack also
haben wir auch da haben wir bestimmt 20
Versionen durch beim Pesto glänzt auch
schön wenn ich so jetzt irgendwie dass
man denkt da ist da ist auch ausreichend
Olivenöl drin dass es jetzt nicht
irgendwie stumpf ist oder zu trocken
sondern das sieht aus das ist schon mal
positiv sehr gut ich bin wirklich gerade
aufgeregt ich merke das totil dass ich
mir jetzt denke es muss jetzt wirklich
muss gut werden dann nehmen wir uns ein
wenig Nudelwasser an dies Seite Nudeln
dazu das ist auch tatsächlich ein großer
Unterschied also bei ganz viel Pesto was
man so kaufen kann covert das nicht so
gut also das das haftet nicht gut an zum
ein natürlich weil das jetzt braen
Nudeln sind hängt auch damit zusammen
wie viel Käse du drin hast wie gut das
bindet Nudelwasser dazu und dann gebe
ich das schon auf den Teller und wir
setzen uns an den Tisch zum Probieren 5
Minuten später metzemanike mit Pesto
erstmal ohne Parmesan mit Parmesan was
sagst du das will ich eigentlich eh
nicht essen okay du kein Problem dann
tun wir den an die Seite es ist es ist
echter Parmesan das ist okay aber ich
find weißt du so eine Reibe kostet
irgendwie nichts ja ist ein andere
frisch drüberelt was du immer weißt ich
mag es total gerne wenn der wenn der
Teller warm ist weil ansonsten irgendwie
zu schnell ich hab gerade mir noch
gedacht ich gerade mir noch gedacht und
es ist ja eigentlich auch kein kein
großes Ding den irgendwie kurz in die ja
in Backofen zu
stellen ja also Duft ist weiterhin
frisch ne und das finde ich finde ich
auch gut dass selbst wenn er jetzt warm
ist der Basilikum nicht irgendwie
aromatisch zusammenfällt es glänzt total
schön also hier sieht man irgendwie auch
dass das Olivenöl das Olivenöl drin ist
und es haftet auch ne also das ist
tatsächlich dass wir eine gute
Verteilung haben von dem Basilikum auf
den auf den Nudeln das finde ich auch
das ist gut schön dass das auch welche
also auch in den Rillen die helfen halt
einfach dafür dass das PE ordentlich
haftet also das finde ich konzeptionell
gut boah ich bin so gespannt gerade ne
find ich finde ich wirklich gut find ich
wirklich gut e mir fällt gerade ein
Stein vom Herz richtig ang schön finde
ich die nudelziehne immer ein bisschen
nach auch es gibt manche die kriegst du
an Tisch dann sind sie aldente dann ist
du und denkst du komch dieses schöne
alent Gefühl ist nicht mehr da die
halten das die sind jetzt deutlich
kühler ich finde auch man muss so ein
Gericht auch kalt essen können ich finde
gerade Nudel mit Pesto sind perfekt um
sie Kal zu essen und deswegen habe ich
ein bisschen bisschen gewartet bis das
bis das kälter geworden ist und auch
jetzt sind die Aromen super schön schön
frisch also dieses ätherische finde ich
super positiv daran und was mich
beeindruckt ist es schmeckt halt wie
Pesto frisch gemacht insofern großes Lob
dafür weil das ist tatsächlich mit ganz
vielen und ich habe auch schon teure
grüne Pestos gekauft einfach um es zu
probieren weil ich dachte Mensch das
sind tolle Anbieter das kostet ein
heiden Geld auch schon aber es war immer
dass die hinter irgendwo gestoppt haben
ja ich weiß genau da fehlt einfach wenn
du 100% Geschmack hast beim frischen
Kochen durch die konventionellen
Konservierungsmethoden fallen 20 30 50%
vom Geschmack einfach weg bin überrascht
das ist sehr sehr sehr sehr gut sehr
sehr gut gelöst ja sehr gut eins von
drei haben den Test bestanden den
Restaurantkritiker Test du hast ja
gesagt Creme Alter tfo gibt als letztes
das heißt jetzt machen wir Spaghetti
Bolognese und wenn wir uns an hert
sollte er schnell gehen was viele nicht
wissen der carsten hat gesagt er will
das wirklich nicht dass ich das mache
aber ich mach's trotzdem carsten hat
schon regelmäßig Bücher auf den Markt
gebracht das sind zwei neue Bücher falls
ihr interessiert seid wir haben einmal
die butterbrotbriefe vielleicht über die
über die Festtage lese ich mich mal ein
bisschen rein das und das kriminelle
Kochbuch Killer schnüpler und Rezepte
passt besser zum heutigen Thema zum
Essen da habt ihr du und ein Freund die
Ernährung von Kriminellen und von
Kommissaren weiter aufgearbeitet wir
haben geguckt was haben die gegessen und
wer Spaß hat an an krimmi und Kochen der
auch Spaß an dem an den Buch haben sollt
ihr euch anschauen falls für euch
interessant ist bereiten wir alles zu
und sehen uns gleich wenn es auf dem
Teller ist so Ksten da sind wir wieder
diesmal mit vorgewärmten Teller was ist
der erste Eindruck der erste Eindruck
ist ein sehr schöner Fleischgeruch das
finde ich das hat man halt bei bei
fertigen bodus die riechen eigentlich
immer nur nach Tomate und du denkst okay
das sollte eigentlich schon es ist
zentral ein Fleischgericht und das muss
auch danach riechen das habe ich hier
ganz ganz stark du hast ja gesagt ein
bisschen sit ist auch drin ich glaube
das Pint dann auch noch mal den
Fleischgeruch ich mag die Farbe das habe
ich eben schon gesehen die Farbe von der
Pasta dieses ganz leicht goldige nicht
zu viel das gefällt mir sehr sehr gut
auch hier dass man sieht von der Bolo
die ist jetzt nicht darauf getrimmt dass
sie ganz ganz dunkel ist oder so sondern
das ist ein sehr sehr authentische Farbe
beruhigt mich wenn ich sowas sehe und
weiß ne hier ist nicht irgendwie
nachgeholfen worden damit damit das
jetzt unbedingt so und so aussieht m
wiederum beruhigt ist wenn du das sagst
deshalb sind wir beide beruhigt und dann
kannst du ja beruhigt probieren geht
schon geht schon gut auf die Gabel man
merkt dass immer noch so ein bisschen
wieder Widerstand ist
ne irre irre aldente also das ist
wirklich jetzt das wird glaub ich
überraschen wie viel bis diese Nudel hat
man muss richtig kauen ich finde das
super und du hast auch immer noch einen
guten pastageschmack also der der wird
jetzt nicht erschlagen von der Bolo
sondern der ist noch
da ja das das find ich gut das war jetzt
mal ein größeres Stück es geht richtig
auf am gaum hier merkt man halt auch die
wirzung die kommt sehr sehr sehr sehr
gut rüber bleibt sehr sehr lange
erstaunlich ist dass man hier die Aroma
die man von der von der lange gekochten
Bolo hat dieses tiefgründigere ne nicht
dieses flachere mit dem mit dem Tomaten
Geschmack und den Gewürzen sondern die
Gewürze die haben nichts frisches mehr
sondern die gehen ganz ganz tief das
finde ich auch gut man sieht ja das ist
wirklich hoher Fleischanteil und nicht
irgendwie sonst diese diese Soßen lachen
die man hat nee es ist Bolo Fleischsoße
fleischsße genau und hier sogar noch
Stücke drin das finde ich eben auch gut
es muss ja nicht alles winzig klein sein
sondern es kann es ist ein rustikales
Gericht und es kann eben dann auch ein
bisschen bisschen größere Stücke haben
wie findest du die Würzung dabei musst
Du bedenken ich habe nicht nachgesalzen
nachgepfeffert nichts weil dazu bin ich
ganz ehrlich paar Leute haben mir gesagt
dass es dass ihn ein bisschen Salz fehlt
das ist natürlich eine Sache die wir
fortlaufend auch anpassen ja nee ich fin
find das vom Salz her genau richtig also
das darf ordentlich Salz haben das find
ich finde ich schon ich finde es hat hat
eine gute gute Würze die aber eben nicht
das Fleisch überlagert was gefällt dir
denn vielleicht nicht so gut gibt kannst
kannst du da sagen weil ich glaube die
Leute denken sonst so redest mir nur
nach dem Mund bin sehr froh dass es dir
so gut gefällt oder so gut so gut zu
gefallen scheint es ist schwierig
tatsächlich da jetzt da jetzt ein Fehler
zu finden also auf Teufel komm raus ist
das schwierig es ist einfach kein keiner
da geil das freut mich doch sehr weil
ich finde selbst auch wenn ich die
Dinger zubereite ne wenn ich
pastapoesier mache und ich denke mir
jedes Mal in ganz vielen Restaurants
kriegt man nicht so eine gute Pasta ja
das stimmt also selbst bei ein Bode wo
man denkt ist eigentlich klar wie uns
machen muss gute Zutaten dann gib ja
Zeit scheitern die da dran nee es
ist tut mir leid echt ich hat es muss
nicht leid also ich freue mir gerade ein
Loch in Bauch ne hast du echt gut
gemacht ich ich hätte es so stark nicht
nicht erwartet dass also einfach dieser
Eindruck ist das ist das ist frisch
gekocht das ist ja das was du erreichen
wolltest und das kommt schon echt rüber
also ich bin wirklich Buff aber ich bin
auch aufgeregt vor dem letzten Gericht
weil du hast gesagt du magst eigentlich
gar nicht so gern trüffelpasta wenn er
mit Aromen gearbeitet wird ich liebe
Trüffel aber ich find trüffelpasta ist
dann eben gegenüber dem was man bekommt
wenn es eine super geile Trüffel ist
fällt das immer total in sich zusammen
so ein gelernter falscher Geschmack im
Prinzip gucken wir mal ob wir den
richtigen Treffen mit unserer Pasta wir
steigern uns langsam diesmal angerichtet
warmer Teller das plating ist ist gut
der Teller ist ist warm ja das finde ich
schon so sollte es an den an den Gast
kommen ich habe echt immer noch die Bodo
am kaum ist so intensiv das ist schon
schon echt hammer ja was natürlich
auffffällt ist dass Trüffel klein sind
ist klar wie willst es anders irgendwie
lösen starker trüffelduft der sich
direkt vermittelt Soße ist so dass sie
tatsächlich aufgesogen wird die liegt
jetzt nicht irgendwie drüber hat man ja
auch manchmal was so eine pampingesoße
hast und die zieht überhaupt nicht
richtig ein das ist ja anders anders der
Fall ja finde ich jetzt tatsächlich den
den schwierigsten Gang für mich ich
finde es eine Nudel wo sich das aldente
eben nicht über überträgt die wird
relativ relativ weich man hat ein
Trüffelgeschmack man hat aber hier auch
das erste Mal dass man die Salzigkeit
des Wassers tatsächlich schmecken
kann ich finde den Trüffelgeschmack okay
von den drei Gerichten ist es ist es
dein dein least favorite ist ist mein
least favorite weil ich glaube hier ist
einfach der Punkt dass dass du beim
Trüffel auch normalise wirst jetzt eben
auch ein paar frische noch drüber tun
das geht natürlich nicht es gibt ein
Trüffelgeschmack der ist auch gut aber
das kenne ich aber auch dass es noch
mehr auf das hängt natürlich auf den
verwendeten Trüffeln ab ihr könnt
natürlich keine Alber Trüffel verwenden
sonst kann das keiner meh bezahlen es
ist halt auch ein Gericht was super
wenig eigentlich Zutaten hat die
aromatisch wirken du hast im Endeffekt
eich fast so die Trüffel das andere soll
eich nur so ein cremigen schlossigen
Geschmack machen und wenn das dann nicht
komplett 100% drauf ist dann dann hast
du nicht diesen WOW Effekt so der BO hat
wowekt h baueffekt hier würde ich sagen
das ist immer noch sehr sehr solide ne
und ich würde mich in vielen Restaurants
auch darüber freuen wenn ich weil ich
find trüffelgerichte werden immer
verhauen weil sie dieses Trüffelöl drin
haben und das sticht richtig und ich
krieg sobrennen davon und das ist nicht
das ist das ist sehr sehr klar aber es
ist jetzt tatsächlich von den drein das
was mir am wenigsten flasht hier ist
halt der alenterpunkt am schwierigsten
zu treffen weil sie so dünne ist also
bei den Spaghetti die hatten die hat
eine gewisse Dicke also ich glaub ein
bisschen frisch im Pfeffer tut dem Gang
auch gut dass du einfach noch mal was
hast was so richtig rauskommt weil es
gerade frisch gemacht malen ist das ist
glaube ich auch noch mal wasit man den
Gang echt echt pimpen
kann da bin ich schon Einflussnahme
Einflussnahme nein ist doch super cool
dann ja bin ich wirklich vor allem sehr
sehr froh dass dir die Produkte gefallen
haben dass du Spaß daran hattest unsere
Mission ist es pastagenuss für Leute
nach Hause zu bringen und einfach zu
machen wenn du sagst es schmeckt dann
glaubt vielleicht der ein oder andere da
draußen auch Mission gelungen ne ich
würde son echt nicht sagen ich meine ich
habe auch Ruf zu verlieren und ich würde
jetzt nicht irgendwie schön reden wenn
es wenn es anders wäre das sind tolle
Produkte es ist eine gute gute Nudel die
nimmt die Soße auch gut auf alle drei
nehmen die nemen die Soße gut auf und
also man merkt einfach dass das
durchdacht ist und und dann vielen
Details gedreht worden ist sonst kriegt
man das so nämlich nicht auf die Reihe
wir kennen Platz 3 wen würdest du auf
Platz 1 tun Pest oder
Bolo oh das ist das ist fast schon fast
schon eine Glaubensfrage ich glaube weil
es für mich noch überraschender war dass
es in der Qualität ist würde ich die
Bolo auf eins setzen weil da doch so
viele Komponenten sind und eben dieses
lange Garn diese diese tiefe Würzigkeit
das finde ich echt eine besondere
Leistung aber es ist eher so weißt du
magst du lieber Äpfel oder bnen ist ist
beides für sich gut bei dem Pesto ist da
ich schon frische Pestos gemacht habe
und ich weiß es sind eigentlich nicht
viele Zutaten ne und eigentlich ist es
ist es eine ganz einfache Nummer
deswegen war das jetzt vielleicht ein
Tacken weniger überraschend wobei es
immer noch überraschend ist weil es eben
sonst immer so muffig ist wenn ich es
irgendwie kriege aus Gläsern aber die
Bolo hat mich jetzt also ich hatte
gedacht das kriegt er nicht so gut hin
ja Karsten dann bedanke ich mich recht
herzlich
sehr schön noch mit dir drehen zu können
vielleicht haben die Zuschauer da
draußen auch noch Ideen was wir sonst
noch so anstellen können mit dir
unterwegs zu sein und so diese Expertise
zu sehen das macht immer Spaß auch für
mich wenn ich nur neben dran stehe
deshalb vielen lieben Dank danke euch
fürs zuschauen und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten Video wieder macht's gut bis
dann ciao ciao